Hawaii this week people have been
filming the huge flows coming out of the
Kilauea volcano on Hawaii's Big Island
this is actual footage of lava
approaching a car that people be talking
about
it's really really pretty intense now
that's just a very short clip we got our
hands on the longer version just check
it out hey Alex its Lonnie from uber I'm
outside your house right now the white
Mustang next to the lava flow okay I can
wait like two more minutes
Alex it's Lani from uber you coming out
you're canceling it okay well we have to
charge you you can take that up with
uber bye you give me one star I'll give
you one star hey Sarah it's Lani from
uber I'm coming through the gate now
white Mustang in a blah blah blah blah
[Applause]
you